The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: By way of review,
we're going to
start off with loops.
So, what are two loops that
we've covered in lecture or
two types of loops?
AUDIENCE: FOR and WHILE.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
FOR and WHILE.
I'm going to start with WHILE
loops because that's what I
have first.
Can someone walk me through the
syntax of a WHILE loop?
AUDIENCE: WHILE condition.
PROFESSOR: WHILE condition and
what type is this condition?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then I have--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And then a block
of code, indicated by
indentation.
OK.
Next question is, what
does this code do?
AUDIENCE:Executes the loop and
returns Boolean values.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's a little bit
too high level.
Specifically, what does
this loop do?
AUDIENCE: Prints the even
numbers from 2 to 10.
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
That's exactly the kind of
comment we're looking for.
When you're doing your problem
sets or you're just coding in
general, you want to have a
comment that describes in an
abstract way what's going on
in the chunks of code.
You don't want to have
a comment that says
assigns 2 to a.
Continues looping
until a is 10.
Comments like that aren't really
helpful because you can
get that by reading the code.
So that's exactly right.
It's perfect.
I don't have candy to
pass out, though.
Next question is what's the
decrementing function?
The way to think of a
decrementing function is that
it's a statement that moves
the loop closer to
termination.
In this case--
AUDIENCE: 10 minus a.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 10 minus
a or a plus equal 2.
As we're incrementing a, we're
getting closer and closer to
10 and that's going to cause
us to kick out of the loop.
Next thing.
Is a a good variable name?
The answer is no, otherwise,
I wouldn't have asked it.
But a better variable name
might be even_number.
Because, instead of just a being
an integer, now we know
what it's supposed to represent
in the code.
And it becomes clearer when we
go to execute it or run it.
For loops, same thing.
Could someone walk me through
the syntax for a FOR loop?
And first question, does this
loop do the same thing as a
WHILE loop?
If this is our WHILE
loop, does this
loop do the same thing?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see.
The WHILE loop printed out 4,
6,8,10 and 12; this is going
to print out, 8 and 10.
The reason is where we have
the increment, right?
If we had done this, they would
print out both the same.
A little aside.
That was a bug I just caught.
Someone walk me through the
syntax for a FOR loop.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A FOR keyword and
then what do we have here?
A variable of some sort.
Then we have in keyword and then
we have this thing here.
We're going to get to tuples
in a second, but this is a
tuple literal.
And for FOR loops, a FOR loop
requires something that is
enumerable, which means that we
can take one element after
the other and assign it
to the variable i.
FOR loops iterate over
enumerable items.
Thank you.
That's exactly what I
was talking about.
If I'm speaking too low, just
jack your thumbs up.
This construction is
inconvenient though.
If we wanted to list all
the numbers that
we wanted to print--
2 to 10 is not too hard.
But let's say we wanted
all the even numbers
between 2 and 100.
I don't want to have to write
out all 50 of those.
So we get to the
range function.
You've seen this before.
We just haven't ever
explained it.
All the range function does is
it takes between one and three
parameters and returns
a list of integers.
So let's say that I pass
it one parameter.
I'm going to give it
the integer 100.
This is going to give
me nothing because I
didn't print it out.
This is going to give
me integers 0 to 99.
If I give it two parameters,
what it's going
to do is give me?
The integers between
1 and 100.
In this case, it starts off
at 1 and it gets to 99.
One important point is that
when you give it two
parameters, the first one is
inclusive and the second
parameter is exclusive.
Does everyone follow that?
Finally, the third form is
with three parameters.
I have a start, an end, start
inclusive, end exclusive, and
then a step.
This will give me all the odd
numbers between 1 and 100.
We can also go in reverse.
If I want to go count down from
100 to 1, I can give it a
negative step.
If you want help on using the
range function, there's a
handy command called help,
which you can type in the
interactive prompt.
This gives you the syntax
for using range.
You can do this for any
function in Python.
It's going to tell you,
here's the name.
Here's a parameter start.
Here's a parameter stop.
Here's a parameter step.
This little arrow here means
this is what it returns, a
list of integers.
When you type help and you see
one of these square brackets
that means the perimeter
is optional.
A start is optional.
Step is optional.
Stop, we always have a stop.
We always know when we're
stopping a range.
That's why we can pass one,
two, or three parameters.
Is anyone confused on that?
AUDIENCE: If you only put stop,
it will start with 0?
PROFESSOR: Right.
If you only put one parameter,
then it will start from 0.
So the start is implicit.
Are we good on this?
So, we can code our FOR loop
like that, which for five
numbers is not too inconvenient,
or is
convenient.
But if we have 500 numbers, it
makes it a lot easier to just
change one end point than
it is to type in
500 numbers, right?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Can you create
a range for floats?
So let's say you want to
do it by float size?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
We should try it.
Why don't we give it a shot?
The question was can we make
a range of floats?
Let's try 1.02 to 10.0.
It'll give us an
answer, right?
But it also gives
us a warning.
It says that an integer
argument is expected.
Let's say I do this.
Will this work?
What's it's going to
do is it's going to
truncate the floats.
It's going to truncate the start
to 1 and it's going to
truncate the end to 10.
Then it'll just return the
integers as required.
So you can, but it doesn't
work the way
you think it would.
Moving on, you hit tuples
in lecture this week.
So we're done with the
old review stuff.
Can anyone tell me
what a tuple is?
It's a non-scalar data type
that can hold many items.
What does non-scalar mean?
AUDIENCE: It's multiple elements
that you can search
individually.
AUDIENCE: It's a field that
you can hold only
one value at a time.
PROFESSOR: You're both right.
A scalar can hold only one
element at a time.
A non-scalar can hold more than
one element at a time.
Tuples are actually the
second scalar data
type that we've seen.
A string is the first.
A string can have multiple
characters.
Tuples are flexible.
We can have tuples of numbers.
This syntax, the parentheses
with a set of elements
separated by commas,
this is the literal
syntax for a tuple.
All we're saying is that my
tuple of numbers has the
approximation of
pi, 2, 1, -100.
We can have tuples of strings.
We can have tuples of anything,
but you'll get to
that in a second.
AUDIENCE: Can you mix the data
types inside of that?
PROFESSOR: Yes, we're going
to get to that.
The question was, can
you mix data types?
The answer is yes.
We'll get to that in a second.
To access individual elements
of a tuple, we do something
called indexing.
We specify an index by--
if I have tuple_of_numbers, my
variable name, I have a left
square bracket and a right
square bracket, and I have an
integer in between.
This would give me the item
in the tuple that
exists at index 0.
Tuples are indexed starting at
0 and in increments of 1.
When I say tuple_of_numbers[0],
what
should this print out?
AUDIENCE: 3.14159.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It will print out 3.14159.
Now if I change this to 1,
what will this print out?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
It doesn't matter what data type
is contained in tuple.
If it's string, it'll just print
out whatever's here,
which is 'what'.
You can also use negative
indices.
Negative indices tell Python
that I want to go to one past
the end of the tuple.
In this case, tuple_of_
strings, I'm out here
somewhere, and then walk
back 1, or however
many the integer is.
I have here tuple_of_strings
minus 1.
Python's going to go to
somewhere around here and then
walk back one and
give me 'name'.
Now what if I do minus 3?
What's that going
to print out?
Is.
Let's see who is paying
attention.
What's this going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: My name,
or name, rather?
PROFESSOR: Remember we index
tuples at 0, right?
AUDIENCE: That's going
to give an error.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
It's going to tell us
index out of range.
We have four elements in
tuple strings 0, 1, 2,
3, oops, we're off.
You can get outside of a
tuple and get an error.
To avoid that--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: The thing is when you
said for tuple_of_numbers,
you said 1 and 3.141, number,
which would technically be 0
in this case, wouldn't it?
PROFESSOR: No, I switched it.
AUDIENCE: You switched it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just to make you feel better--
AUDIENCE: I see it now.
PROFESSOR: You got it?
OK.
It's always possible that
I made an error.
In your code, in order to avoid
that, you can check
yourself by getting the length
of tuple_of_numbers.
So there's a function len.
It's going to tell us that
tuple_of_numbers has 6 elements.
We can count them:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
What's the last index
of this tuple?
5, right?
Back to your question, tuples
can hold different data types.
They can hold data types that
are different from each other.
I'm wording that improperly.
So, here we have a float
and three strings.
This is a heterogeneous
data structure.
A homogeneous data structure
would be one that you would
say only hold ints only
holds floats.
But tuples are very flexible.
So, we have a float here
and some strings.
Then you could also
have tuples that
contain other tuples.
In this case, how many
elements does
tuple_of_tuples have?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3.
The first element is a tuple,
the second element is 'got',
and the third element
is 'real'.
What should this print out?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I had to sanitize that quote.
AUDIENCE: Why does it print
out the strings?
PROFESSOR: Python's behavior,
when it sees a tuple data type
and you call it with the print
statement, is it represents as
a string a tuple the
way you would
literally write out a tuple.
'Stuff, just' is a tuple
with the two
strings 'stuff' and 'just'.
Python is going to print out the
literal representation of
that tuple.
Another way to try and explain
it, let's say that I print out
the entire tuple.
What should this look like?
Well, It's going to be
just the literal
representation of the tuple.
What does it mean for the data
type to be immutable?
AUDIENCE: You can't change it.
You can't add another
element to it?
PROFESSOR: You can't
change it.
If I try to change the first
element of tuple_of_numbers,
it's going to tell me
it doesn't support--
or Python's going to tell me
it doesn't support item
assignment.
You'll see this error.
Tuples support something called
slicing, which means
that if I have a
tuple_of_numbers
and I give it a--
where I normally put just a
single integer for an index,
if I give it a start index and
an end index, separated by
this colon, Python's going to
get the item at index 1 to
whatever this end element
is minus 1.
It helps if I just
print it out.
To make it a little bit
easier to follow.
I've said I've told Python that
I want a slice out of
this tuple from 1 to 3.
What Python's going to go do is
look into tuple_of_numbers.
This is element 0.
This is index 1; it's
going to pull in 2.
This is index 2; i it's
going to pull in 1.
Then 3--
in Python, we go 1 past the end
of the range that we want.
It's going to return
a tuple of 2, 1.
This is slicing a tuple.
Anyone confused by that?
No?
Wow.
There are many different ways
that we can slice a tuple.
We can have an implicit start.
If you see this, where there's
no number before the colon,
that tells Python start
at index 0.
Then, in complimentary fashion,
if you see this,
where you have an integer on the
left side and nothing on
the right side, it tells Python
go from index 1 all the
way to the end of the tuple.
What happens is I do this?
What's that telling
Python to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It looks redundant but it will
become important to us when we
get to lists and something
called aliasing.
What this does is it tells
Python to take a slice that is
the entire tuple.
Then when we do these
slices, we can also
use negative indices.
This is going to tell Python
to go from 0 to the last
element minus 1.
It'll look like that.
Everyone following?
We good?
AUDIENCE: It was minuses
from the end--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --of the tuple?
PROFESSOR: Okay.
I wonder if this would work?
I don't know.
No, it has unexpected
behavior.
I don't know why.
I'll have to look that up.
Tuples are also--
we already said earlier
that they were
enumerable items, right?
So we can use a FOR
loop with them.
If I want to print out all the
numbers in tuple_of_numbers, I
have my FOR loop, my variable,
in, and then
my enumerable object.
OK?
I have a question now.
Who thinks this will work?
We know that tuples
are immutable.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But you have to change
the inside.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's going to work.
I still have print up here.
What I'm doing is I'm taking
tuple_of_numbers and I'm
printing before.
Then what I'm doing here is
I'm telling Python to take
this tuple and this tuple and
add them together and reassign
it back to tuple_of_numbers.
So, It looks like I'm
modifying the tuple.
But in reality, what's
happening is I'm
creating a new tuple.
Let's say I have ton here.
Ton is short for
tuple_of_numers.
Originally, it's telling Python
that some chunk of
memory has a tuple
of 1, 2, 3, 4.
When I say a statement like
ton equal ton plus another
tuple, what it's telling Python
to do is create another
chunk of memory that includes
ton, whatever's in ton, and
the other tuple.
Then this assignment statement
tells Python that ton now
points to this new object.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE:Does Python have
a garbage collector?
PROFESSOR: It's an advanced
question.
The question was, does Python
have a garbage collector to
discard this memory that's
no longer being used.
The answer is yes.
If you don't know what a garbage
collector is, don't
worry about it.
You don't need to.
But to answer your question,
yes, it does.
I don't want to get
too far into it.
Does everyone follow that?
That also is going to be
important when we get to lists
and aliasing, that type of
object creation modification.
We won't get to that
for a while.
Everyone's good with this?
I can move on?
All right.
Python has what some might
consider a wart,
when it comes to tuples.
That is when you want to create
a tuple with a single
element in it.
People just starting out with
Python would sometimes mistake
the tuple literal of a single
element to be this: So,
parenthesis with a
single integer.
The problem is that parentheses
are the grouping
operatorS in Python,
but they're also
used for making tuples.
They serve a dual purpose.
What Python will say is, oh,
I've got a number between two
parentheses.
Well, this person really wants
this integer to have high
precedence.
We're going to make an integer
50 and assign it to oopsie.
But it's not what we want.
We want a tuple with
50 as one element.
The way you do that is you have
a lone comma after the
first element.
If we run this and we look at
what it prints out, you see
that oopsie has the integer 50,
which is not what we want.
We want what's in onesie.
Anyone confused by that?
We're zooming along here.
Strings, they're actually
a lot like tuples.
They're immutable.
You can't change them.
They're non-scalar.
They have multiple characters
within them.
If I printed out-- everyone's
seen this--
I can get to individual
characters.
If I want to get to the first
character in name, I use 0.
If I want to get to the second
character, I can use 1.
Then of course they're
immutable, so that's going to
tell me that I can't do that.
They also support iteration.
So, if I want to print out all
the letters in name, one on
each line, I can do this.
Not too useful, but it works.
You looked confused.
AUDIENCE: How did that happen?
PROFESSOR: How did
that happen?
So, name is a string.
Follow that?
String is just a bunch
of characters.
It is enumerable, meaning that
we can go one character at a
time through the string.
That's what the FOR loop does.
AUDIENCE: Do spaces count
as characters?
PROFESSOR: Good.
The question was do spaces
count as characters.
The answer is yes, they do.
If I write spaces there and I
run this again, as I iterate
through the string, I get a
space where I'm supposed to.
Is everyone good with this?
OK.
Like tuples, you can
take slices.
That's going to give me 'it'.
Strings also have
many functions.
This is an incomplete list of
functions that you can use on
string objects.
I can make everything uppercase,
lowercase.
I can also find characters.
What find does is it
finds the index of
the left-most character.
If I want to find i, it returns
1, because i is at
index 1 in the string.
I could also do something
like this.
I can find an entire string.
'tch', the substring,
starts at index 2.
AUDIENCE: What does it return
if it can't find it?
PROFESSOR: If it doesn't
find it--
let's put in garbage--
you get negative 1.
We can also call a
replace function.
If I want to replace
m with p--
it doesn't make sense
anymore--
I can do that.
The question is, how would I use
this to change the string?
Think back to how we
modified the tuple.
We created a new object and
then we assigned it to a
variable of the same name.
If I know that replace is going
to return a string with
m replaced, I can do that.
Does everyone follow that?
AUDIENCE: Is the version
that that
captures your string function?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
That also gives me a perfect
opportunity to demonstrate
another command that you'll
find helpful.
If you're working with an object
like string, you can
use a command in the interactive
editor called dir.
If you type dir str, it's going
to return all of the
symbols that exist within
the str object.
You can also type help str, and
it will give you a nicer
version of this.
AUDIENCE: In this case, the
first character indicates what
you're trying to replace and
the second is what you're
replacing it with?
PROFESSOR: Right.
We can do help str replace,
and it'll tell us.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it did one.
And then the count in this
case would be if you had
multiple instances?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So like if you had your name
a couple times, you could
replace it a few times.
PROFESSOR: Right.
If I were particularly
narcissistic that day, I could
replace it multiple times.
So let's demonstrate
that because some
people might be confused.
Let's say, I want
to replace t.
I'm going to replace
it with r.
Whoops.
Well, why didn't it replace
these to t's here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
In strings, you differentiate
between
lowercase and uppercase.
If I wanted to get the behavior
that I was hoping
for, I could do it this way.
Now I have something that's
not even remotely
looking like English.
Or, I could do something
like this.
I'm going to make everything
lowercase, and
then replace the t.
AUDIENCE: So that's
pretty exact that
you have to be, lower--
PROFESSOR: Remember what I said
first recitation that
computers will do exactly what
you tell them to do and
nothing more or less.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: It's good though.
It figured out [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Python is a
very nice language.
It's one of my favorite
languages right now.
Because, it's not as fussy as
some other languages, like
MATLAB or C or C++ or TCL.
Anyone of those.
Is everyone good on strings?
I can move on?
Just remember, if you need help
on any of these commands,
just remember you have the help
command at your disposal.
AUDIENCE: It'll automatically
default to do everything,
unless you tell it something to
do like two of the letters.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We didn't demonstrate that.
Demonstrations are worth
a thousand words.
If I wanted to, for whatever
reason, only replace the first
two t's, I could tell it to only
replace two t's within
the string.
It leaves the other t alone.
AUDIENCE: How would you pick
out the last field?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
I don't have a ready
answer for you.
You see these functions with
r in front of them?
The string object often has
functions that will start from
the right side as opposed
to the left side.
The find command I showed you
has an rfind command as well.
This guy right here.
I'm pointing on if there is
the analog to replace.
Can I get back to you?
I don't want to spend all our
time searching for this and
then fail spectacularly.
I'll get back to you on that.
Is it possible?
Yeah.
Is there a one-liner function?
I can't tell you
at the moment.
But again, that's why you
have dir and help.
You can find this
out on your own.
Next thing, BREAK.
We're done with strings.
We're done with tuples.
We're still working on loops.
Everyone's seen this function
before, right?
This is our find-the-cube-ro
ot-of-a-perfect-cube function.
If I give it 27, and I tell
Python to stop printing my
name, that's what this does.
As a toy example to illustrate
the BREAK statement--
first of all, can someone tell
me in English what the BREAK
statement does?
AUDIENCE: Would it just
stop the program.
PROFESSOR: Well, It doesn't stop
the program, but it kicks
you out of the loop.
We can rewrite the cube root
program to work like this.
Instead of our stopping criteria
being answer cubed
less than the absolute value
of the number, we're just
going to tell the FOR loop to
go from a range 0 to the
absolute value of the
input plus 1.
Why do we have the
plus 1 there?
AUDIENCE: So it goes to the
absolute value of x.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Because, otherwise, it would
go to 1 before the absolute
value of x.
Then we break out of this loop,
if answer cubed is equal
to absolute value of x.
As soon as we see that it's
equal to x, we're going to
call BREAK.
That's going to immediately kick
us out to here, without
executing any more
of the FOR loop.
Do people understand that?
Are people good with that?
AUDIENCE: Does it break you
of the innermost loop? or
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good question.
Does it break you out
of the innermost
loop or all the loops?
The answer is the
innermost loop.
When he says innermost,
what he's talking
about are nested loops.
Let's say I have something
like this.
I'm creating on the fly
now, so excuse my
inability to type.
What is this going to do?
This is an example
of a nested loop.
We have an outer loop
here, then we have
an inner loop here.
All the outer loop is doing is
it's going from the integers
0, 1, 2, 3 to 9.
And then we have an inner loop,
which looks like it
should go from the integers
10 to 100.
But we have the statement
in here if j mod 2--
that's what the percent
sign is, modulus--
is equal to 0.
What we're saying is if j is
evenly divisible by 2, we're
going to break.
Now, the question is--
this is obviously going
to break when j is 10.
This loop is going
to execute once.
The question is does it print
out only one set of i,j
values, or does it
print out 10?
I'm getting to the answer
to this question.
If BREAK statement breaks out
of all the loops, then we
would only see one printout
of i and j.
But if it only breaks out of
this inner loop, then we
should see 10, followed
by 'here'.
So it breaks out of
the inner loop.
Long answer, but
demonstration.
Is anyone confused by that?
Is so, anyone too
shy to admit it?
There's office hours.
Or, you can talk to
me afterwards.
PROFESSOR: Now we're going to
get to functions, which are
triple underlined and circled
over here because they're
extraordinarily important
for you to understand.
Can someone wing it and
tell me what they
think a function is?
AUDIENCE: It's a snippet of code
that takes some input,
does something to it, and
returns some output.
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
It's a bit of code.
It's named, so you
can refer to it.
It takes input, does something
with it, and returns
something, some value.
The way that we define a
function in Python is like so.
Let's say I have a
function cube.
It consists of a few parts.
We've got the DEF keyword.
We've got a name, cube.
The name should be meaningful
for functions.
Like variables, the name should
mean something So, this
would be a bad name
for this function.
You want it to be meaningful.
It has a set of parameters.
In this case, it only
has one parameter.
This is what we pass to the
function when we call it.
We'll talk about that
in another second.
It has this string.
This is called a doc string.
It's the specification
for this function.
When you write functions, it's
good to have this string here.
What it allows you to do is
describe what the function
does, what it expects for
input, and what it
gives you as output.
In this case, it's
very simple.
This is the body of
the function.
Again we denote the block
by indenting.
All it does is it takes a
number, which is passed into
it and raises it to
the third power.
This RETURN statement tells
Python to send that back to
whoever called the function.
As an example if this working,
let's look at
this line of code.
What it's doing is--
we've seen the print
statement, so we
know what it does.
It's going to name cube and
it's going to call it.
Python knows it's calling it
because it's got the name of
the function with the
input parameters.
So, 3 is being passed to cube
to be, well, cubed.
What's going on here is that
Python is breaking out of its
normal flow of execution,
sending 3, calling it number
in the function, and then
raising it to the third power.
If we run this, we see 27.
We can pass it any number
that we want.
Is anyone confused by this?
AUDIENCE: The things you're
running between quotation
marks, doesn't that kind of--
PROFESSOR: They don't
do anything.
The question was, this string
here between the quotation
marks, this doesn't
do anything.
No, this is a comment.
This is so that you can tell
yourself, six months down the
road, what you were thinking.
Or so that you could tell
another programmer what this
function does.
It's a way of documenting
your code.
AUDIENCE: So cube in this
case is something that
is built to go around.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is just a toy example.
I wanted to keep it simple.
I'm illustrating concepts.
It wouldn't be too hard
just to do this.
I'm going to move on.
Everyone's good with
functions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Can you say x equals number--
can you keep the number, and
just keep the number, and just
make it into a variable without
the RETURN function.
Do you have to use the RETURN
function on that?
PROFESSOR: I was just
getting to that.
The question is, do you have
to use a RETURN function.
The answer is well, it depends
on what you want to do.
So, let's take a look
at a new function.
Can someone tell me
what this does?
First, what does the
function do?
Or what is it supposed to do?
AUDIENCE: Takes the number
and doubles it.
PROFESSOR: You got that by
reading the writing on the
wall, right?
Really, it's too easy.
In the body of the function,
all it does is it creates a
new variable, answer, and it
assigns number times 2 to it.
What's going to print
out here?
Why don't we run it and see?
That's not doing
what we wanted.
When you don't have a RETURN
statement, Python returns
implicitly none to whoever
calls the function.
Ok.
In this case, this function
obviously doesn't have a
RETURN statement Python
says, OK.
I'm just going to return none.
Whatever work it did in the
function is lost in this case.
To get the right functionality,
we have to add
a RETURN statement.
And it works.
Was that what you
were getting at?
OK.
Anyone confused?
Can I move on?
Functions have something
called variable scope.
I apologize for the punning.
I was getting tired
when I wrote this.
In this chunk of code,
I define a
global variable, all_hope.
I also define a function that
takes a parameter, variables.
It says it steals all the
variables, but I don't know
how it does that
in a computer.
It doesn't return anything.
In the body of the function,
I create another variable,
called my_variable, and
I assign it a string.
I'm not actually returning
anything right because I've
said I'm not returning
anything.
All this is doing is it's
just printing stuff out.
It's printing out what the
parameter passed into it was.
It's printing out variables.
It's printing out all_hope,
which is a global variable
that we define up here.
It's printing out my_variable,
which is a local variable in
the function.
Down here I'm defining a
variable, old_meme_is_old.
I'm calling the function.
It does what we expect
it to do.
What I want to illustrate,
though is what
happens if I do this?
As you might expect,
it's going to give
me an error, right?
The reason is that my_variable
has local scope to this
function, all
_your_vars_are_belong_to_us.
Is anyone confused by this?
No one's confused by this?
OK.
Let's try something else.
Let's not do that.
If I run this code, we can tell
from the function that
it's taking one parameter.
It's incrementing
that parameter.
It's incrementing this
global int that
we've defined up here.
It's returning the parameter
that it's just incremented.
Erase my corny humor.
The question now is, let's say
that I have a variable y, and
I give it a value of 10.
I'm being completely
arbitrary.
If I call the variable, inc_it,
on y, first of all,
what's going to print?
If I print out the value of
y, what's going to print?
We want to run it.
Uh-oh, I'm failing.
I'm stepping on myself here.
This is why you don't debug
code on the fly.
If I have a global variable and
I need to reference it, I
use a global keyword.
You should never have
to do this.
Ink_it is going to
return 11, right?
Because it's taken y, which
is 10, and it's called x
equal x plus 1.
Then it's returned this x.
If I look at what y is, after
I've run this, y is still 10.
This is because when we've
passed in x here and we've
called x equal x plus 1, it's
actually shadowing itself.
It's overriding what's in
the local parameter.
But it's not overriding the
actual variable, y.
We'll get more into
this later on.
The important thing to
understand in this case is
that the changes that you make
to this parameter stay within
the function.
We good?
All right.
I need to move pretty quickly
now to gotchas.
I guarantee you someone's going
to make this mistake.
Print is not RETURN.
When you call print
print_is_not_return, it's
going to call this function.
It will print out this
string, but it's not
returning the string.
What it's returning
is none, because
there's no return statement.
That's where this
none comes from.
RETURN is not print.
So, if I say print this return
value, it will print this; it
will return a string.
But if I just call this, it's
not going to print it again.
It's going to print nothing.
You'll just have to
make the mistake.
One thing to be careful
of in Python--
remember I said everything
is an object?
Functions are no different.
Functions are objects.
If you just reference the
function's name, cube, which
is not defined now, it's going
to print something out that
looks like that.
This is what the object
looks like to Python.
In order to call it, you have
to have the parentheses with
the parameters.
Python's not going
to complain.
Some programming languages
will complain.
Python won't.
It's possible when you're
running your code, if you're
trying to call a function and
you forget the parentheses,
and Python's just not
complaining, it will merrily
do what you tell it to do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
can you speak up?
AUDIENCE: Print q open
parentheses [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is x defined?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.